this program is brought to you by Emory
University this is beautiful and it's
going to be even more beautiful when the
trees are often the park is finished it
only took about 10 years but the
revitalization of emory village is
nearly complete marlene goldman moved to
druid hills 15 years ago she says it's
been a long time coming my husband I
used to joke that we hope we live to see
it and we did the impetus to redefine
the village started in 1999 when CBS was
planning to lease the building that
previously held Kroger when the rumor
started that CBS was going to buy the
kroger people just went up in arms there
wasn't a yard and druid hill that didn't
have a sign in it with a CVS flashed
through it a compromise was reached and
CBS moved in but those discussions led
to the formation of the Alliance to
improve emory village the Alliance
worked for the neighborhood the county
Emory and local businesses on ways to
upgrade the area what the Alliance to
improve memory village wanted the
neighbors wanted was to create a more
viable emory village that you know that
could become a place to live and to dine
in and shop in it play in and we think
this is the beginning of that after nine
years of planning and many difficult
discussions and decisions construction
began in august two thousand ten before
it featured a five-way intersection with
traffic lights each way which forced
backups and long waits it was a barrier
between Emory University and the village
today the lights are replaced by a
roundabout that slows traffic but keeps
it flowing smoothly the power lines were
buried sidewalks were widened and
pedestrian crossing lanes were more
defined as brick paths one of the big
concerns was pedestrian safety that was
that was huge and and quite frankly
we've been very fortunate not to have
had fatalities over the years with
people crossing over from campus to get
into the village north decatur road was
narrowed from four lanes to two lanes
with a center turn lane and bike paths
on both sides the idea was that someone
who had to make a turn could pull into
that turn lane
and not keep all the other traffic
backed up and behind them emory village
is about ninety percent complete the new
park still needs to be built and more
than 50 trees will be planted in the
park roundabout and along the sidewalks
Emory made a sizable donation to create
the park and the Alliance is continuing
to raise money through a fundraising
campaign this rendering is what the
village will look like upon completion
from the beginning Emery has supported
the roundabout and the Alliance's
efforts the University moved its front
marble walls back and made its main
entrance a one-way road to accommodate
the roundabout it's just an amazing
transformation of the entrance I mean
this is our front door and it should
look like a front door it should be a
beautiful entrance to what is a
beautiful campus Willison goldman hoped
the new emory village will become a
vibrant place for neighbors students and
faculty to interact and hopefully
attract new businesses to the area for
emory university communications i'm cory
broman folks
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University